jetzt freue ich mich sehr dass wir
ausgerechnet in dieser praxis verschiebe
woche einen echten europaabgeordneten zu
gast haben fünf jahre lang war er
reporter der heute show und dann hat er
quasi sein leben weggeworfen und ist
nach brüssel gegangen über die zeit da
hat er natürlich das unvermeidliche buch
geschrieben und heute ist er hier
martin sonneborn meine damen und herren
fußball wieder vorbei
all den jahren
genau wie im europaparlament genau so
wirst du da auch begrüßt lasst uns die
aktualität einfach ganz schnell abhaken
damit was hinter uns haben die briten
sollten sie überraschend doch noch
austreten in diesem leben werden sie dir
irgendwie fehlen in diesem parlament ja
ich glaube schon mein vater hat mir ein
angebot gemacht in seiner fraktion
einzutreten auf dass ich leider nicht
eingehen bin damals aber nie wurde mir
fielen auf jeden fall
zwischenrufer andere form von demokratie
viel lebhafter viel konzentrierter gegen
europa arbeiten als die rechtsradikalen
zum beispiel
du hast ja eine interessante forderung
gestellt habe ich gelesen du hast mal
gefordert dass nach dem break sind im
europaparlament nur noch deutsch
gesprochen werden darf
was ist daraus geworden das ist komisch
daran ich glaube die also erstens geben
wir deutschen den takt an
in europa und die auf allen wichtigen
führungsebene ja zum beispiel die vier
wichtigsten kommissions- posten sind mit
oder verwaltungsposten sind mit
deutschen besetzt drei von ihnen den
vierten hat einen der eine als
nachfolger eines deutschen und als
vorgänger auch vermutlich wären wir
sagen das schon recht direkt wo es
langgeht ich habe das verfolgt und ich
war stolz deutscher zu sein in europa
kommen ja die ausländer brauchen wir im
prinzip nicht aber er will nur noch
deutsch gesprochen werden darf er das
ein riesenverlust weil wir da nie wieder
oettinger englisch sprechen hören das
ist kenne ich schade er hätte ich gesagt
das ist rein
ich glaube man tut mir nicht weh wenn
man sagt du sitzt in diesem parlament in
der ecke bei den verhaltensauffälligen
ja es wirklich so vor ihm sitzt ein
polnischer monarchis der fordert das
frauenwahlrecht abzuschaffen zum
beispiel also das ist wirklich die freak
ecke sagen wir ganz allgemein was kann
man denn bewegen als fraktionsloser
abgeordneter also eigentlich nicht viel
als ich dann kam ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass irgendwie politik machen kann und
ich hatte nicht den anspruch da etwas zu
erzielen aber ich hab das ja auch nicht
doch ja ich habe übrigens immunität also
sei etwas vorsichtig hier ja natürlich
ich habe abstimmungen entschieden zum
beispiel eine datenschutz abstimmung die
der rat noch blockiert im moment ich
habe mich in einen ausschuss gemogelt
hat mit einem schmutzigen
geschäftsordnungstricks udo voigt
ersetzt und für den eine stimme ab den
npd war den npd mann den ich da
beobachtet haben und mit ihr sollte das
zu denken dass die leute den unterschied
zwischen dir und dem npd man nicht
gemerkt haben
oder ja das stimmt es gibt mir auch zu
denken jetzt wächst es gerade was aber
in jedem fall keiner bestreiten kann
der martin sonneborn hat mehrere sehr
schön reden im europa parlament gehalten
einige sind viral gegangen wie man heute
sagt wir haben ja einen ganz kurzen
ausschnitt aus einer rede von dir da
ging es in der debatte über den krieg in
syrien und die bundeswehr und achten sie
aber auch mal darauf wie brechend voll
die ränge des parlaments sind die
bundeswehr allerdings können wir nicht
mit schicken die ist kaputt
die könnte höchstens defektes
militärgerät aufsatz ballast abwerfen so
ein leopard 2 aus 8000 metern höhe
knallte ganz schön rein ähnlich übrigens
wie die deutschen nato posten abgeben
[Musik]
man könnte
man könnte es so zusammenfassen wenn du
redest kommen wirklich alle
man könnte es anders interpretieren
viele arbeiten nebenbei ich bin jetzt
heute show ja mein kollege elmar brocken
179 kilogramm konzentrierte cdu muss
nebenbei aufgaben wahrnehmen für
bertelsmann zum beispiel
es ist nicht so dass man sich da
komplett auf seine politische tätigkeit
konzentrieren kann oder muss
außerdem gab es applaus wenn auch von
drei leuten ich habe mir noch mal
angeguckt wie das war als zu 2014 auch
zu deiner eigenen verblüffung rein
gewählt wurde ist in dieses parlament
keine aufnahmen vorjahr 1 1 1
naja ich habe nur noch mal gegoogelt was
du damals in interviews gesagt hast und
das war lustig wurde es wirklich fast in
jedem interview gesagt du würdest in
jedem fall nach einem monat wieder
zurücktreten was ist dazwischen gekommen
ein gesetz also der parteienrechtler von
arnim hat uns relativ schnell darauf
hingewiesen dass ist eine vorschrift
gibt die relativ schwammig formuliert
ist das parlament hätte lediglich
vermuten müssen dass ich gegen den geist
der verträge von lissabon verstoße mit
meinem rücktritt ich wollte eigentlich
59 parteifreunde dann monatlich
nachziehen damit die alle mal hoch
dotiert einem monat in brüssel
verbringen können und die nicht gefragt
muss ich sagt ja wir haben jetzt haben
die leute aus der heute show die jetzt
nachkommen mit nico seinem spot aber du
kannst in fünf jahren wenn du hier
ausgebrannt ist nie über dich
es ist sehr viel höheren haut kriegt da
mein brot an der seseke nach europa
schicken
das hat tradition in deutschland ist es
auch nicht mehr ja das war nicht nur die
besten wiedergeben
[Musik]
hatte in mehreren interviews ebenfalls
gelesen dass du nach einem sehr starken
oder feststehenden schema ab stimmst im
parlament du stimmst und eigentlich
immer abwechselnd mit ja oder nein ab
egal wie die frage ist kannst du
verstehen wenn leute sagen die zeiten
sind zu ernst um seine stimme einer
spaßpartei zu geben ich fliege zu
antworten dass die zeiten zu ernst sind
um nicht eine satire stoff zu reagieren
ich stimme abwechselnd ja und nein
einfach weil das sehr viele abstimmungen
sind teilweise bis zu 240 in 40 minuten
aber wenn es wirklich wichtige
abstimmung gibt werde ich informiert von
interessierter seite und wie gesagt ich
hab ja auch drei abstimmungen aus der
luft weil wir sagen wenn es wichtig wird
er die grünen die linken und die
sozialdemokraten wird zu sehr schöne
stimme brauchen sagen sie bescheid wenn
es knapp wird wir haben eine grupo haram
im europäischen parlament eine unselige
große koalition genau wie in deutschland
und kleine parteien haben da keine
chance das geht alles mit großem abstand
durch ich habe mir eine aktuelle umfrage
angeguckt danach steht die partei bei 2
prozent das würde reichen für dich
vielleicht auch für samstag 2 das sind
nur 14 prozent weniger als die spd
seid ihr jetzt mainstream seit jahren
muss ich mir sorgen
also ich finde es immer noch eine
demütigung 14 prozent hinter der spd
ich glaube dass wir beide noch daran
arbeiten dass der abstand sich
verringern
wenn es klappt
wenn es klappt für dich im mai dann
hättest du am ende zehn jahre
europaparlament auf dem buckel ist man
danach überhaupt noch resozialisierbar
ich komme dann gerne zurück wenn das
angebot wahr
wir haben hier immer ein warmes
plätzchen würdig martin für weitere
videos klickt unten und abonniert auch
unseren channel alles im kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße